[Música]
en parís las orillas del sena son una
atracción cotidiana tanto para sus
habitantes como para los turistas
el río atrae cada año a millones de
visitantes lo que hace de él uno de los
lugares más frecuentados de la capital
para brindar seguridad y proteger este
espacio toda una comunidad se moviliza a
cotidianamente
cada mes este técnico de la ciudad de
parís se dirige a las orillas del sena
toma una muestra del río para analizar
los 10 años ha observado un verdadero
cambio visible a simple vista
y
la calidad del agua no era la misma que
la actual
la transparencia del agua en clase
hay veces que están reapareciendo
nos dirigimos al laboratorio de la
ciudad de parís
las muestras del día llegan a la mesa de
trabajo
esta es el fuerte de acuerdo
la evolución industrial disminuye desde
los años 80 pero los desbordamientos de
alcantarillas aún ponen problemas
encontramos muchas cosas en especial
rastros de contaminación relacionada con
la presencia de seres humanos en
especial rastros de contaminación fecal
y es este análisis que nos permitirá
medir su concentración
la calidad del agua mejora pero no lo
suficiente para autorizar la posibilidad
de bañarse desde 1910 se le hace
seguimiento al agua del sena en estos
archivos se anota todo incluso los días
en los que no hubo análisis durante la
guerra algunos eventos impidieron la
toma de muestras falta de electricidad
en mayo de 1944 por ejemplo así es el
barco suspensión no está mal
en el cena el baño está prohibido desde
1923 bueno no para todo el mundo ellos
son policías fluviales del río la
brigada fluvial
a lo que le hago seguimiento es que no
haya embarcaciones que se acerquen por
seguridad
[Música]
en el entrenamiento de natación lleva
una hora cuando de repente suena una
llamada
[Música]
alerta de ahogamiento se trataría a un
niño esta vez no se trata de un
ejercicio la marcación avanza más de 60
kilómetros por hora
[Música]
freno en seco los policías observan una
forma en el agua
deben ser transeúntes los que llamaron
lo vieron de lejos y creyeron que era un
niño de verdad
mejor así sí
los policías de escena hacen unas 2.000
intervenciones como esta al año pero no
todas terminan así desafortunadamente
[Música]
cerca de 100 personas mueren en el río
anualmente salvar vidas no es la única
misión de la brigada fluvial
los policías exploran también el fondo
de escena con un radar
esta técnica permite localizar vehículos
hundidos y a veces incluso cuerpos
también tesoros inesperados
meta4 de los cultivos en tierra se hace
mucho
es una carrocería que está un poco más
abajo
no está en muy buen estado pero aún se
ve la estructura de la carrocería con
las llantas que están más bien en buen
estado aún
[Música]
cada vez más ciudadanos se movilizan
para extraer estas estructuras de los
ríos en las orillas del canal de oveja y
segundo incluso un entrenamiento para
los jóvenes se le llama pesca con imán
el jugador
pero no
clínicamente
era pesada y pesada les da alegría sacar
algo así pues no se dice que ya no está
en el agua entonces sí es una gran
satisfacción
momentos bicicletas el canal está lleno
se necesita un imán para localizarlos y
luego el gancho hace el trabajo
este gancho
como desafortunadamente hay muchas
bicicletas motos agarra bien
estas burbujas en la superficie son la
señal de que los desechos se separan del
paño el año pasado estos jóvenes sacaron
11 toneladas de chatarra de los nuestros
vecinos siempre están las ganas de
encontrar algo histórico algo raro algo
de valor se trata de una tarea ecológica
con el ánimo de descontaminar una parte
del botín será re vendida a chatarreros
pero antes de hacerlo hay foto
obligatoria podremos algún día bañarnos
en estas aguas sin desechos
contaminantes mientras tanto el comité
de los juegos olímpicos de parís de 2024
decidió organizar competencias de nado
libre en el cen a prueba de que la
naturaleza está retomando
progresivamente sus derechos en este río
capital